[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
entier comment il les a toutes ces
années bien moins mais mieux
alors aujourd'hui ça nous les nous les à
la petite ferme à la plaine des cafres
l'est les frais il fait bon il fait beau
on est chez christian christian on va
faire visite à new son exploitation
agricole et il va nous parler de ses
pommes de terre les pommes de terre en
gratin de pommes de terre frites
pommes de terre dans un bon carizza
pommes de terre vient autre diana diana
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
les abeilles vont dans la fosse
dans les hôpitaux
[Musique]
on attend il faut
habitons ma
tout est question d alex comment il est
à talons ça va bien en fait on se
connaît depuis très longtemps mais bon
je te faut pas dit à personne
alors christian diamant où ça nous les
ici nous nous les sur le piton mao donc
le monsieur la peine des caf à 1650
mètres d'altitude et dima donc
d'exploitation donc c'est ça une
exposition agricole
même si une petite exploitation agricole
qui est en fin de compte qu'ils étaient
avant qui appartenait à mon beau père
quand cette exploitation l'a donc la
nounou c'est la troisième génération de
ma femme surtout troisième génération de
planteurs de pommes de terre
mais avec le temps on a voulu changer
quand même parce que là les pommes de
terre c'est bien s'aimer c'est la
monoculture le fait de planter de la
carotte change de plantes et de la pomme
de terre bien sûr donc ça ça t'enlève
cet effet de répétition de train train
quotidien
on en met un petit peu tout ça alors
voir à l'hôpital en allant voir ça parce
qu'il faut regarder enfin voyons
[Musique]
planquez vous aimez
c'est tout
m
[Musique]
la note rappelle un peu la pente type
essoufflé alors demain on a quand même
m² angola ici là entouré la faisant bas
avec le ballon me travaille sur
l'équivalent là n'a à peu près 8000 8000
m² quand même oui comme 8000 m² on va
dire c'est pas des grosses exploitations
mais le 8000 m² pour ça que me fais
aujourd'hui les lampes le mans suffisant
leur amplement surtout moi vous parler
maintenant
hors caméra hors champ où vous voulez
dire quelque chose sur le bio j'étais
dedans pendant sept ans le bio c'est
devenu du bio business d'accord voilà
quand tu fais prendre un produit un
produit bio certifiés bio dans un
supermarché
le produit il a passé dix mille
kilomètres déjà c'était mieux donc
chambre froide tout ce qui s'ensuit donc
ok on allons favoriser le bio allons
faire du bio mais permettons à aux gens
qui font du bio d'utiliser les matières
naturelles le naturel mais aujourd'hui
le naturel dérange l'industrie parce que
l'industrie eux font avec des molécules
ça va vachement plus vite et ils
s'approprient les molécules
il s'approprie l'adn donc ensuite donc
toi en tant que même en utilisant des
produits naturels
on te dit non tu n'es pas biologique toi
parce que tu es produits ne sont pas
certifiés bio voilà c'est ça c'est ce
qu'on te dis aujourd'hui on va parler on
va arrêter de parler des choses qui
fâchent voilà ça c'est humain parce que
bon alors tu sais quoi
moi je veux continuer à visiter un petit
peu moins alors à l'eau ben oui
quelqu'un qui tue et wario là où j'ai
engagé des racloirs la louve
[Musique]
matin
vous tenter
tenue à montanou la rate mon talon se
trouver là donc cette pomme de terre
elle est terrible on était un rival et
dormans c'est la ratte du touquet qui
s'appelle pommes de terre de bush dit de
bouche que les on va dire les grands
restaurants à issers va donc le prix de
la semence nous coûte déjà juste à
l'achat 3 euros 50
d'accord donc pour l'instant à la
réunion je suis le seul à le faire ont
donné la tat la tsr il est la
quintessence du monde vous irlande en
mode on est obligé de steam et aux mains
dans la terre toi tu m'épates hama dans
la terre mais ça va pas dans sa tête ou
quoi et s'il atteint ti-boutte cours
chacun un petit endroit où que nous
sommes là plusieurs techniques comme ça
même si on à l'espace est réduit
on a des jardins on a des des potagers
verticaux qui peuvent se faire dans des
petits cours des petits potagers dans
des gouttières tout est possible de
faire il faut faut vouloir faut vouloir
le faire et si vous arrivez à faire ça
vous avait cet amour de sa le pour moi
goûter le fruit de votre travail et en
ville on peut faire pousser énormément
de choses
comment pour l'amour de la nature pour
le bios
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors le noir et vos côtés de carreaux
pommes de terre ouais alors donc
rappeler quelles variétés de pommes de
terre natale à celui-là en fin de compte
ça va arrêter là c'est la sylve arrêté
assez particulière elle et elle est
bicolore d'accord s'appelle la blue bell
c'est quoi la particularité de cette
pomme de terre
la particularité du ccfa donc j'ai pas
le goût terrible
franchement c'est une pomme de terre
dite de bouche donc le que tu tu fais
des frites avec ça te fait des frites
super doré avec un goût il ya un mois le
irréprochable les minimes ont tous un
petit peu la couleur l'on regarde un
petit peu ça la ma plante sanaa trois
mois comme si tu veux la comme moi je
mets pas de jeu mais pas de produit rien
sur sur l'asp la conservation le seul
moyen de conservation qu'on peut avoir
pour les pommes de terre c'est de les
laisser en sol donc c'est le voilà sous
terre donc le souhaitez à la ils sont
vraiment conserver
c'est la meilleure chambre froide qui
n'ont pas avoir ici en l'air je m'en
avait parlé d'une technique doit faire
germer tu pense qu'on peut la voir bah
oui oui oui de secret secret de ces
crêtes christian allons donc déjà des
branches de brinvilliers web un gibier
on prend toutes les feuilles normalement
là une fois le trou fouillé nous ce
qu'on fait oprean moi je prends des
palettes de bois de palettes de bois
avec un deux trois bois secte que la
dent le koala et nous mettre au milieu
les palettes de bois ou chauffe le trou
une fois le trou bien chauffé nous
retient toute la braise que là dedans
mais prendre ombrage ailier on va
essayer que me tapis que le tapis
surtout la partie basse ensuite
on prend les reprend les pommes de terre
qu'on met direct sur le trou ensuite on
reprend un autre lot de brens géniez on
recouvre les pommes de terre avec une
fois couverte
on reprend de la terre et met 200 euros
mais de si au bout de deux semaines
ce qu'on va voir apparaître ses lacets
ça bon allez petit peu de films gm
dessus les petites chèvres dessus comme
ça dessus bonbek ou de pareil en
question ip est bête mais bon le monde
connaît pas des fois comment plants de
pommes de terre
comment porte à pommes de terre oui
excusez moi brager lien il fait ça et ça
aussi en fin de concours d'imagés il est
là il faut pas il faut éviter respirer
dedans tout est gratuit grâce gratte la
gorge donc à londres un petit peu plus
haut là bas et nous va voir comme ça
monte à 7 vitesses et comment il porta
le rôle communauté mais bon
[Musique]
savez-vous planter des pommes de terre à
la mal à maintenir à la mode de
christian mwami c'est comme ça où mes
trucs mettra ce petit canal on lire
c'est pour parer à halo comme ça quand
l'eau y est arrivé à isa rester là et ça
coulait donc normalement on essayait de
préconiser que la pole que le gym se
soit vers le haut si les vers le bas va
prendre plus de temps à pousser
donc on met toujours bien en l'air
essayer qu'on les voit bien sûr un
ensuite nippon petit peu de fumier et là
maintenant nous attend là c'est parti
pour trois quatre mois trois mois et
demi sur et j'ai dû mettre à peu près 1
kg simple on peut avoir entre 8 kg lui
qui lors du kilo retirer
[Musique]
copie mais bataille est fatigué de la
ville et
[Musique]
alors que l'instant nous voilà posé avec
un joli petit caisson de légumes là les
très appétissant en tout cas ça c'est
sûr ces jolies des légumes c'est bon
pour la santé
diamant comment il arrive à la cua la
base de têtes de d'exploiter comme ça
décès soit agricole et de l'étrave à la
terre ne connaissait pas que mal est
fait ce travail là mais on avait une
petite prédication de ma mère qui est
humain comme ça un jour du christ yon où
là on va terminer qu'une purge hautement
vous dis pas l'arrivée
bah tant mieux c'est dix fois moins
qu'aux malades là ma femme à mes
questions
papa il planqué à bout de pommes de
terre on est là mais ce monde un petit
bout type l'emprunt tu bats allons
essayer de faire une affaire donc là
commence planter ses haricots là au même
moment
passons à demande l'autorisation mon
beau père robert curieux il vient voir
mailly en cas d'accord validé et
approuvé un plan des haricots mythique
or c'est pas saison des haricots la
arena où vivait sa rentrée arrête
plantes au pas ça vient ou maladie filet
de pommes de terre en bas l'abba plantés
il ya d'hommes à 10 filets de pommes
d'isère il ya deux ans - le légume qui
allait avec
il ya deux mois tout ça et c'est ça
aujourd'hui qu'à permettre à moi
aujourd'hui de nouvelles voies de fait à
sa monnaie mais à côté de ça nous avons
très vite parce que vous êtes au fait de
la musique aussi conduit dans les champs
on a toujours un petit un petit truc
nous ferons demain à faire je me dis
voilà donc le c'est un truc que nous
connaît pas et c'est ça que nous
redescendre à la can édité chez rim a
trouvé un petit un petit truc là et du
coup elle a fait une chanson
dernièrement qui s'appelle dans le piton
mao on a fait le toit et parce que oui
on a fait le tour ben écoute moi celle
de redescendre dans les bars mais mon
ami jason viens viens viens battre carey
python mao gare à la prochaine tia
beaufort travail ali rallye nous va
rallye
alex tu oublies pas chemin ne brûlera
pas chemin et tous les samedis 1 100
pièces zoug est pas mon ti an oll et à
nous laisser à pied au marché forain
c'est vraiment bien
tous les samedis matin
et allez traverser trappe bref des
compagnies et toute cette pomme de terre
et plus vite que ça s'il vous plaît bon
là trouveront frère et voilà messieurs
dames
l'émission se termine mais promis mi
juin va revenir je vais revenir chez
vous très vite en attendant je vous dis
au revoir
j'ai passé une bonne semaine voilà on
nous on s'est arrêté juste en descendant
vers 23e petit endroit pour balader
c'est juste terrible je vous dis donc
revoir à la prochaine et away détail
important
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
[Musique]